we're here to talk about gaming for the
greater good i one of things i want to
delve into is what that means is the
greater good the right uh moniker for
this that implied one thing and then in
reading through the uh the topic uh
clearly that's broader than what i think
of is uh sort of colloquially the the
greater good but we'll get into that in
in a few minutes let me let the
panelists introduce themselves and what
they do briefly there will be points for
clarity and brevity
and uh
and then we'll jump into some other
topics here maybe i'll start with you
molly
clarity and brevity okay molly kittle i
run the client services team at
bunchball we're a company right down
here in the valley
we have about 50 large
enterprise customers who use our
platform and our consulting services to
add game mechanics and game dynamics to
non-gaming environments
dot dot
great um my name is nicole lazaro and
i'm a consultant in the game industry uh
for the past 19 years i've run zeo
design and essentially i make games more
fun
i'm most known for having the audacity
to ask the question you know can games
uh make us you know change how we feel
and i used
uh in 2000 2003 2004 i used paul ekman's
facial action coding where you measure
emotions in the face to out really
unlock what makes games fun
so that's that's that's what that's what
i do
hi my name is mark nelson i
research mass collaboration and mass
interpersonal persuasion here at the
stanford persuasive technology lab
and last year we also spun out a new lab
stanford peace innovation lab where
we're essentially trying to take
everything we know about
using technology to elicit
desirable behaviors
and
build a platform where we can measure
how much impact we can have doing that
okay i'm byron reeves i'm a professor
here at stanford
in the department of communication i'm a
media psychologist i do empirical
experiments about how people think and
feel in relation to uh
interesting features of interactive
technology the last six years uh we've
been uh chasing the juicy features of
multiplayer games
in the lab i'm also a co-founder of a
startup called seriousity and we're
trying to take game mechanics and game
sensibilities and psychology uh to the
enterprise and figure out pl figure out
how to build a venue that is a game
where people can go to work
environment we'll stick with you and uh
maybe just explain game dynamics broadly
speaking what are they and why do they
work and everybody can add in but yeah
well i'm sure we'll all have our own
list chapter four in total engagement
uh by reeves and reed uh is is our list
uh and you know i won't go through them
all but uh there are mechanics that are
reliably used in games that have been
successful over the years that engage
people
you started out with one of them
points for
for brevity
but
levels
teams different features our list
actually is that we tried to take from
uh the social science literature about
how uh these games work so we're very
interested in in feedback and the time
domains of feedback uh games do really
well in short time domains uh your your
workplace might do well in annual
reviews or not even that well in that
time scale but so feedback is very
interesting there's notion of social
interaction and teams and cooperation as
well as competition it's very
interesting the
the mechanic of self-representation
finding some way maybe it's a full-blown
avatar maybe it's some other way to
represent yourself but
vesting uh
something of you in the interaction on
the screen
is terribly engaging and we know that
because we're looking at people's brains
why they while they interact with
avatars so all these i mean there's a
long list i don't know how
how long you want to get this there are
lots of lists available uh but it's it's
taking these mechanics from tried and
true uh recipes in these games and and i
think this whole gamification exercise
is really
figuring out how we can take them and
drop them in other contexts other than
just entertainment where eyeballs are
the criterion and and try to come up
with some other metrics to to apply them
to i have a shorter list
so in terms of game mechanics um and
really i really love you guys this book
and the work that you do uh what we've
done by looking at people's faces as we
uh
uh found that people playing everything
from tetris to halo home school and work
young and old you know diner dash world
of warcraft uh we found that you know
player we basically we videotaped them
and uh looked at those favorite moments
and organized them by um uh by emotion
so we had these emotion clusters we had
four basic groups and we looked at those
emotions and well what were the
similarities and types of the types of
choices players we're making it turns
out that games tend to engage us best
selling games uh in four ways the first
way is uh what we call hard uh oh
usually it's the first one is the hook
it's the novelty it pulls you in we call
it easy fun it's you know basically just
being able to drive around the track or
maybe drive the racetrack backwards
throw all your sims in the pool pull out
the ladder
driven by curiosity wonder and surprise
you've done that yeah
i've done it too
the second one is hard fun which is all
about challenge and mastery so it's the
it's basically it's that frustration
because that basketball hoop is way up
there and it's really small uh that
leads to this feeling of winning like
yes you know i got the boss monster i
won the grand prix uh no word in english
for that emotion so um i use i use fiero
you know the italian for you know like
yes i got your body's on fire that's how
i visualize it and uh you know that's
goals obstacles and challenges and
obviously points uh the third one is the
ability to uh socialize around games so
we found the games a lot of emotions in
games best moments and games happened in
a social context games are excuse an
excuse to hang out with your friends so
you have what we call people fun which
has amusement and schadenfreude which is
the joy you feel uh when your rival
experiences misfortune you also have
nakas which is a yiddish term for that
pleasure and pride when someone you help
succeeds lots of great emotions more
emotion and people fun than in the other
three combined
and uh people playing the same room have
more emotions than play that than
playing the same game in different rooms
a lot of social interaction around that
so not surprising i mean we released a
smile in 2004 it took us a while to get
on facebook and actually get some good
social games
um but uh you know so that's where we're
at in the last one is of course serious
fun
and the serious fun
is the serious fun key is all about uh
the ability for a game to actually
change how i think and feel and behave
after the game is done i've gotten some
reward and it's sometimes it's a badge
but more importantly it's now i'm
smarter i've lost weight because i play
ddr or that i'm you know closer to my
friends or some value that that game
experience creates players enjoy games
that actually change change how they um
how they are all games teach
um so those are the those are kind of
the four keys and then mark had a
question for you and i'll bring it back
to you molly um is this multicultural
are these
um
you know fundamental ways people think
and behave and react or have you found
that not to be the case
so um
there are levels of this that are basic
biology
um we don't think of ourselves this way
very often but we human beings are
actually a herd animal we're right in
there with the gazelles and the zebras
and so forth
and um
that means we're we're hardwired to
collaborate and cooperate much more than
we are hardwired to fight with each
other
um
and so if you want to trigger those
endorphin hits and and oxytocin uh jolts
and so on um if you're coming at this
from a business perspective you should
think of yourself as a drug dealer
dealing legal drugs
and you should be thinking about
how do i trigger what biology has been
hardwiring into us for millions of years
in terms of
social bonding this feeling of
connectedness the feeling of being part
of something greater than ourselves
um
all of those things are deeply wired
into into our biology
i agree but i think i disagree on the
drug dealer part
legal legal drug dealer well i think i
think that what you what i do is i
really draw from the patterns and then i
you know model a pattern you know in the
real world to you know model what you
know model game mechanic around it
and um if uh if you go too hard like if
you create a skinner box skinner boxes
work they're very reliable very
predictable but if you create a skinner
boxes skinner boxes it will have the
behavior but it doesn't they're not fun
you know you're just addicted to the
game and it's actually then caused a lot
of pain so you have to be careful if you
go too
yeah yeah and so molly that was uh
really leads nicely into my next
question which was
does it have to be fun
no it doesn't have to be fun in the
sense that we think of fun
um
i think enjoyable
satisfying gratifying fun i think
frankly has gotten a bad rap
fun can be
scary to a banking website fun can be
scary to
a ceo who's trying to increase
productivity in the workforce but i mean
the term fun
the term fund can be yes but the innate
human fun absolutely um so i guess it's
important to differentiate between the
word and the emotion um that's one of
the things that really when we did our
research about fun was so interesting
and why i wanted to say well people were
banding about this term fun well what is
that um and it we really mapped it more
towards engagement you know because
there's a way of engaging but that it's
interesting that hard fun is different
than easy fun sense like hard fun is
actually you know my favorite player
quote is you know a wife of a hardcore
piece of game and she says i always know
how my husband feels about a game if he
screams i hate it i hate to hate it i
know two things a he's gonna finish it
and b is gonna buy version two
so when we have fun we are often working
we are often experiencing a lot of
frustration in fact the only way the
arms go up for a nice fiero is when
you're so frustrated about ready to
throw that mobile phone or whatever it
is out the window
and that's when you succeed at that
point that's when that's when you went
um
joey mentioned
the topic is gaming for the greater good
is that a
good topic we're talking about a variety
of things here when i read that topic i
thought this was for
social change in the
um
npo sense of the
world not business not necessarily
education is gaming for the greater good
um
the right i would want to argue with
that okay like you know the only way
we're going to get greater good is if we
change business
i mean it's got to be integrated um i
follow a lot of what kevin jones says on
this and it's sort of like he has this
metaphor of you know you work at an
office you know for part of the day or
for all of the day you come home with
money in your pocket you then go to a
charity and then you know you in one in
one pocket and then you put you know you
had another pocket and pull out money to
give to the charity to
uh reverse the damage that was done by
the the hours you put in at the office
so i think something about that system
could be a little bit more optimized
perhaps a little more efficient but
so i don't buy the complete bifurcation
but yeah well i think there's um
we're just looking at a narrow slice of
this and we we built on a lot of byron's
work on engagement um
we realized at some point in the in the
peace innovation lab that
if you look at positive engagement and
there's some buckets of that you know
you've got to get people from ignoring
each other
we'll ignore the negative side of
engagement how to reduce conflict but if
you just get people from ignoring each
other to being aware of each other to
paying attention to communicating these
these are all things we can measure we
can measure the quality and the quantity
of those kind of interactions
a little bit of coordination a little
bit of cooperation each one enables the
next layer basically when you get out to
collaboration where you have people
doing things for mutual benefit
that's a really good proxy for peace for
us
and and that's completely measurable and
quantifiable in in lots of beautiful
ways um and this the more work that gets
done in web-based platforms
the more
hard metrics we have about um
exactly what's possible there i don't
know how many of you have seen the work
we did with facebook but
we can measure
um
interactions that that are directly
representative of some aspect of peace
in really interesting ways so just for
example 67 113
pakistanis and indians friended each
other on facebook yesterday
we never had that kind of data before
you know that precision that scale
um
and that dynamic like they could give us
trailing data by the minute if we if we
ask for it so
um
yeah i think there's there's huge
potential here
to change the world for the good in
really interesting ways i think and i
think um game mechanics is a a toolbox
that we simply have never had before
that i think takes us pretty close to a
new human superpower
in the in the same way what i mean by
that is in the same way that for most of
history we were looking up at the birds
going oh if only we could fly like the
birds but we can't and then a hundred
and some years ago suddenly technology
came together in interesting ways and
suddenly within a decade we were flying
further and faster and carrying more
than any species ever
that's what i mean by a new human
superpower i think we are on the verge
of that kind of potential
for collective action i think just add a
couple more examples one of our clients
um uh builds a game on facebook called
uh it's uh called happy oasis takes
place in the middle east uh and you
click on camels instead of cows
and if you can imagine um 60 of the
population in the middle east is under
the age of 24.
imagine the sort of you know the the
kinds of changes that you could actually
make through you know in terms of
collaborative you know game mechanics uh
you know in that you know with that with
that kind of population you could
actually uh create social bonds that
cross
tribal lines
and i think that's um that's that's
really amazing that what we what we
might be able to do and in fact what uh
you know games have always led uh the
interface design industry uh in terms of
new interfaces so we've always you know
there were pie menus in the sims there
was gestures on the wii you know there's
voice control all of these things have
happened in games first so it's it's
there's no question in my mind that the
even if if we can't have a specific game
you know that actually changes the world
we're going to be able to prototype uh
you know new types of dynamics new
superpowers uh to create uh new ways new
days ways of dealing with each other i
mean the game that we're working on
right now uh with my company which is
called tilt flips adventure in 1.5
dimensions
and i've used these model the model of
four keys to fun to actually i created
the first game on the iphone and use the
accelerometer
uh with joe hewitt at iphone dev cam and
we've now got a bigger version of the
game on the ipad which i can show you
later if you like
and what you do is you earn till points
by eating carbon out of the air and
gathering plants planting seeds those
still points are geocoded so we've got
people playing from here to shanghai and
now we're partnering with companies to
do things in the real world so like with
the vermont energy investment company
they're a line item on the vermont
energy bill we're actually taking some
of their we're actually working on some
games to uh actually have people do
stuff in the real world to conserve
energy they earn points in the game
uh so there's some there's some really
interesting powers that was where i
wanted to go next and this is really
relevant to everybody i'd like because
you have different perspectives on it
but are we talking primarily about
online or a combination of of online and
offline and i know byron that's near and
dear to some of the things you're doing
so maybe yeah i actually think one of
the more interesting uh developments in
the games is the as the
the blurring of that distinction between
online and offline and this is terribly
engaging when you
if you turn off the lights in your house
a smart meter recognizes that electrical
use is down
and through that data is transferred to
uh to your game screen and you get 10
points on your iphone or the carbon
monster dies or or whatever it is we've
worked on that game as well then your
house becomes a joystick for play on a
screen in media and the same in
transportation and health if it's a a
blood test uh uh insulin
related test
uh and adolescents are cooperating uh to
to to uh see what group can
have the best uh uh scores uh and and
compliance that can be input into the
game as well and transportation driving
there's lots of interesting new uh uh
car
uh possibilities for games because there
are sensors in the world that are
providing automatically a lot of data
about what's going on so you get this
blurring and that is terribly engaging i
mean there's no
as part of our work here over the last
20 years there's no switch in the brain
that that that that
flips when you go from real life to to
mediated life and so it's it's very
important to to recognize that that
blurring can really create a lot of that
engagement so i'm i'm very high on the
ability to if you're if you're working
in a company and what you do on your
screen how you resolve a call that's
come into a call center influences how
your team does in a virtual game i mean
that can be a very uh engaging uh
blurring of those two worlds so i really
like that uh possibility for for new
games how are you playing it molly
uh there's a couple of different ways
we're applying it and then also in in
the in the industry opower is a company
that's not a customer of ours but i find
what they're doing
incredibly compelling because it's the
it's the
now version of the dream that byron just
uh that you just just uh mentioned so
when any anytime we pay attention to
what someone's doing they optimize for
the metric that we're measuring and
opower just basically gives you a
a point of reference where you sit in
relation to others in your neighborhood
in terms of energy consumption
you either are consuming less or more
and if you're consuming more you get a
sad face and if you're consuming less
you get a happy face and so people are
changing their behavior to optimize for
the happy faces um and uh and that's
that's uh a great example of something
very offline but incredibly tangible and
impactful and non-complex
the the other
point i want to make about employee
productivity byron you mentioned you
want you want people in a call center to
answer more calls there's a company we
work with called liveops and they have a
distributed call center these employees
aren't actually employees they're
contractors so liveops has no ability to
mandate that they take training that
they show up to work and so how do you
organize and corral a workforce that is
uncontrollable and they've used game
mechanics and game concepts to help them
do that by rewarding users for taking
training getting certifications
displaying their badges other
call center employees can look at badges
and and proficiency and come to certain
people with questions so they're really
motivating a community even though it's
distributed there strikes me that
motivating force organizing force
scoring mechanism what have i missed in
the well
you do have to be careful especially
with scoring uh points are what
unbalances twitter and in fact you know
this gamification idea can actually kill
okay if you remember if you've ever
driven across the bay bridge you know
that they've introduced the the game
designers in the bay bridge have
introduced a variable toll rate to
encourage off rush hour travel off-peak
travel which actually works you know
people more people drive when it's not
rush hour but don't be on the bay bridge
at you know that toe plaza at 6 59 pm on
a friday night because literally
there'll be dozens of cars pulled over
on the medium people stopped in the
active high in the active lane
looking at the scoreboard
waiting for that toll to drop from six
dollars to four dollars
you know basically if you give people a
score they will optimize to you know
they'll basically change their behavior
to optimize it but then there are
secondary effects and so when you're a
game designer that secondary effect
those tertiary effects that's all what
goes that that all goes into indie games
the other thing too is the um
games also have each choices in the
games have emotion profiles so like you
know with the iphone it's a very social
device which is which is great uh and
it's really genius what they did on the
operating system because like if i were
to take my iphone and share my photos
with you well you know we would what
would you do you would well you would
tap you'd pinch you zoom right to look
at the photos well you do those same
gestures but on the back of my hand
you know we better be on a date or
something
because there's so much social emotion
meaning in those gestures and how lovely
for a social device
you know to actually map those into into
the platform so game design is not just
about points but it's creating these
player experiences these emotional
experiences that people that people go
to
there's no one if you think of what are
the top facebook games you know since
the beginning they've always involved
people plants and pets
all of those mechanics uh all of those
mechanics are you know engendered
caretaking kind of things has nothing to
do with points and badges i mean they're
definitely there's there's definitely
good mechanics there but there's other
stuff happening that creates uh
something that really matches that
social platform
um
mark and byron um
what is this
uh
these game dynamics application of game
dynamics how do they affect leadership
and what skills leaders need to have how
they approach
leadership and and then also you know
beyond leaders the folks that leaders
are interacting with
yeah so we did a year-long study i did
this with tom malone it was an hbr piece
about a year and a half ago
looking at leadership in the more
complex multiplayer games so this is a
world of warcraft version where we we
actually went to uh
ibm
got permission uh
to ask middle level executives to fess
up that they'd spent 500 hours leveling
up to level 70 and we're leaders of
online guild and making websites and
doing recruiting and performance reviews
and whatnot in these complex guild and
we actually looked at how leadership uh
happened in those in those guilds and
how it compared to real life and a
couple headlines are really interesting
one is that uh so first of all these are
substantial organizations that happen in
these games this is not a farmville type
type play this is more sophisticated
play but it's worthy of emulating i
think
so these are substantial organizations
that are over months and even years that
can involve tens and hundreds of people
uh in a hierarchy with the sharing
mechanisms performance reviews as i
mentioned a need to
settle disputes and want to one of the
things that the games provide that
really influenced ideas about leadership
is enough metrics enough quantification
enough information enough transparency
about expertise about how people are
doing about who contributed what to to
the rate even uh your damage per second
or your contributions per time unit
there was enough information that
leadership seemed to be more a property
of the environment of the games then of
an intrinsic quality
of the individuals that were doing the
leading so it's not you're born to lead
and we just need to find the right ones
and mentor them but it's you lead now
i'll lead tomorrow you seem to be doing
better on this task you go so uh
leadership happened very quickly our
transitions happen very quickly and the
environment became a a substantial part
of that uh that that that leadership
which is really uh
kind of an optimistic uh view of
leadership that if you provide enough
transparency if everybody knows what's
going on uh first of all everybody can
be a better follower so leadership is a
little bit easier in that in that
respect as well so
imagine uh so what we've done is imagine
taking that transparency that happens in
in world of warcraft and dropping it on
um
a large national retail sales chain what
if all 200 000 people that worked in
your company knew everything about
the sales activities of those 200 000
people so you could find out
uh you know the the the guy at the
jewelry counter in akron ohio and you
know what fantasy team he was on and uh
or she was on and what uh points were
being collected uh teams being formed
uh quests being uh
and that transparency really has an
interesting uh uh opportunity to open up
leadership so it's not that supervisor
but i know what you're trying to do
you've got a hard job supervising us all
i'll help out and and our team will win
and i get to share in in in the spoils
of the team victory
how much how much of that do you think
was uh also uh
how much of the factor that you were
actually in a play environment do you
think that that helped how did that
influence you know you're in a play
environment so it doesn't really matter
if i fail as a leader how many how big a
role did that play in well the fact that
mushrooming is yeah that's a good
question the fact that failure doesn't
quite hurt as much as i think
important but uh and it may hurt even
less because it is in a play environment
but but it can hurt uh if i've got a
hundred friends uh that that i'm playing
with and i look bad in the raid that's a
that's a knock and it and it's every bit
a real knock and it's uh i'm i'm going
to be depressed in my social
relationships that evening uh
equal to a bad day of work so
that the social part of it is is is very
much there even though it is is a play
environment what the what the uh
managers are about several hundred
managers that we interviewed at ibm what
they said was
i believe it's the same thing it's the
same process i'm taking things from the
game world and applying it at work and
vice versa well and
i mean in that context
this is all that's all volunteer labor
so to speak that's people taking their
free time not time they're being paid
with and if you fail them as a leader in
that context
it doesn't have certain ramifications
but it certainly has other ramifications
you don't get to keep your position
because you have a title
and there's an orc structure you are
only there by virtue of people saying we
will follow you well
it might be an interesting
thing to do in real life if that wasn't
the case as well as
i think just to
add and maybe nuance this a little bit
the
leadership is becoming much more
collaborative that's really clear um
and the
the pieces of that that seem to be
really important are about
it's much more now about creating an
environment that people want to come be
part of
and so so leadership ability suddenly
becomes much more about nurturing about
pushing from behind about supporting
your people about pushing them forward
providing a platform for them providing
a spotlight for them getting out of
their way
those all seem to be really identifying
factors and this is
i've been going through this personally
i mean when i uh retired from banking
was early 90s and it was very much a
command and control organization people
did what i said because i paid them and
damn it if they didn't i fire them you
know um
that doesn't work anymore especially in
an organization where you have a whole
bunch of volunteers working for you
because they just love the project and
they care about what you're doing um so
that's been culture shock there's one
other issue though and and that is
a whole lot of things that we used to
think were leadership
are actually management and
administration
those things are getting embedded in
software those jobs are going away
and anybody who thinks that's leadership
should be paying attention to the fact
that
that's getting architected into the game
mechanics
and there won't be people doing that
anymore and that will be a good thing
because now all the politics
that goes with those kinds of gatekeeper
jobs
is becoming much more transparent in in
the software itself people trust
software more than people
in that situation
the interesting thing the theme that i'm
pulling out of that too as far as like
what is a core game mechanic is that you
know games are and what fascinates what
pulled me into games from the very
beginning is that games are i did a lot
of user interface design you know for
you know roxio and you know a number of
different other companies um and uh what
was interesting oracle that sort of
thing is that we get um uh games are
self-motivating tasks you know there is
nobody you know holding a you know a you
know performance bonus or something like
that for you to learn photoshop i mean
for for you to learn world of warcraft
you know you are paid to learn photoshop
and so there's a lot of interesting if
you look at games for their interfaces
and what is it that they do it creates
this nice um you know this nice this
nice self-motivating and that's you know
how do we you know how do we master
challenges like with hard fun we can
actually use these games to figure out
well how do we apply some of these
things take them out of games and then
put them in into um
into into the work itself so for example
i just gave a talk at the game
developers conference and in this um for
the smart uh for the smartphone summit
and what i did was i threw up a slide
with you know like this futuristic you
know like what would a task look like
and uh one of the parts i most like is
just we should have like this little
distraction radar like a heads-up
display for an interruption that's
coming but before so i can squash it
before uh before it gets to me now we
don't want to actually like maybe
actually visualize it that way but
there's a lot of ways that we're going
to be able to change how we work and the
tools in which we work with yeah they're
really you know they're really we're
basically like we're implementing flash
cards right now and the tools we're
going to have in the next generation
they're going to be much more responsive
to what naturally motivates motivates us
as people and that's i think the key is
that this is all about what naturally
motivates us and this is the tool set on
top of those natural motivators that
extracts them puts them to use in
whatever type of environment for
whatever type of goal yeah and if you if
you think about it you know cubicles i
mean let's face it you know cubicles are
cages for people
if the workplace were a zoo the humane
society would shut it down in an hour
because it's not suited for it it fails
to provide the mental furniture for
people to do their work
we spend so much time you know in
facebook because all social you know
social interaction has been extracted
from the task
we spend so much um you know we um we we
we caffeinate ourselves because the work
is fails to engage us
and so we can look at things that you
know software that does engage us for
these cues and what is it about this you
know how does how does wow work you know
how do we get leaders that way and we're
going to change the way the the
workplace works
that brings me back around to sort of an
earlier topic i'd like to dig into a
little bit more just this idea that
we've they're game dynamics and we've
made that this big thing and some of
these are fundamental and they're
cross-cultural and all that but
applied to a business context versus a
more social organization
business context versus some of the work
piece studies those applications versus
educational applications are they
the same are we retargeting the same
tools or
are they different
i mean how
what are some of the tools that you all
use at bunch ball versus mark some of
the tools that you think about or the
the ways you apply it
we haven't talked really about education
at all
maybe we can dig in i'll just sort of
open that up but i'd like to get a level
deeper on those
i think all of us are talking about
recognition transparency feedback and
all of these things
work very well in i think any
environment we can think of where human
beings are interacting
with work with play
socially
all that the tools that i use on a
day-to-day basis for customers
seem a little bit
ten more tangible than the than the
ideas behind them but i point points
that you mentioned levels leaderboards
badges
but those things in and of themselves
that's not the weight that's not the
importance and that's not the motivating
factor they tap into what's already
happening inside of us so you brought up
a good point earlier that and if you're
not if you're not a good choice
architect then you're going to set
yourself up and your users up for
failure so it's all about designing the
experience and taking into consideration
yes your business goals you have to make
money there is an end goal for the
business but there's also
almost more importantly the people that
are driving your business generating
revenue um roi for you we can talk about
that and we can you know thinking about
how we're
measuring and collecting data telling
that the turn on investment story for
engagement
all those things are important but you
won't have a return on investment unless
you're thinking very seriously about the
user experience how they're interacting
with the um either the website the
application the game whatever it might
be and what they want what their
identity is who they are and what
motivates them you asked earlier about
do these things
impact everyone in a similar way or are
different types of people impacted
differently we're all uniquely
individual but we do have a common
motivating factor we all do want to be
recognized and we all are looking for
feedback and i think that what we've
ignored for years for or not for decades
is that the importance of play in as
human beings especially in the developed
world uh i grew up i spent half of my
childhood overseas and it's quite clear
to me that these um that we've really
relegated play to you know sort of this
outside that's just for kids not us but
all games teach and play is actually
really all mammals play play is a very
important part in the learning process
whether it's you know learning your abcs
or learning how to you know create a
balance sheet
uh and so our tools don't don't allow us
to play uh but if you wanted to take it
into here's some some guidelines is what
i do to create a game out of anything is
you want to sim first uh simplify the
world
uh you then can clarify the goals
that'll tap into shakespeare's flow you
know so if you look look up him as well
and then you want to amplify the
feedback mint.com works so well is
because you can set those goals and wow
i've never seen progress you know like
bars charlie like that just they're so
fat very like you know you feel if you
can really feel your progress along the
way and to that um and to that purpose
i've also shared white papers on my
website and uh i'll i'll let you guys in
too i just gave i just opened this url
for the game developers up in san
francisco uh it's uh called uh 4k2 at
four keystephan just4k2f.com
uh and that's routing you to a new page
and you can actually download what i
call game g-a-m-e it's basically the
game plan and you can create a game plan
uh to save the world and what is a game
but it's goals actions motivators and
emotions so g-a-m-e and this little
spreadsheet people cause change so there
are 13 questions that you answer and you
can do it about 15 minutes you can
create a new game to save whatever part
of the world you want to
so how many of you guys are actually
social entrepreneurs or want to be
social entrepreneurs again just
so
the the thing one thing to pay attention
to that's really interesting here is
this toolbox of gamification allows you
to look at something that wouldn't
normally be thought of as business
and start actually quantifying what what
value is and so um
a lot of people look at what we're doing
and say peace innovation isn't that
charity or philanthropy or else
government diplomacy
turns out actually it's not it's
business um
we can go in
we're working on a pilot right now with
partner cities focused on gang violence
and we can start mapping
what impact gang violence has on
property values and on the tax base
and on
mortgage portfolios of banks and lenders
and on insurance claims we can start
quantifying that in a great deal of
detail and saying this is exactly
how much this problem is costing you as
a property owner and you as a community
member and you as a business and we can
identify the businesses where that pain
aggregates then we can go to them and
make a very interesting pitch about how
we can minimize their risk or actually
increase the value of their portfolio
etc so
pay attention to that kind of model
because this toolbox allows you to go
look at things that were traditionally
in the non-profit we can't figure out
how to do business there we can't figure
out how to make the markets work there
things were traditionally in that domain
suddenly become
really interesting new business
propositions when you have this kind of
a tool i just wanted to pick i think
there's a great question of what's the
difference between
the social
metrics and criteria and business
criteria and whatnot
i want to
make a little bit of an admission i
think we'd all have to that an interest
in serious games is really an interest
in a portfolio of tools and solutions
looking for problems
to solve and and the same basket of
stuff can be used to
make a call center work better to
have volunteers contribute on a
website uh
get people to reduce energy use so it
really it but each of those different
metrics and and problems are rat can be
radically different and there's an
alignment process that where you bring
your bag of stuff that works in in games
the ingredients for different recipes
and you really have to spend a lot of
time asking about exactly what in this
call center is going well and not well
and what are we trying to optimize and
minimize and align those metrics and
it's really a difficult process it's not
just a you know through a dart through a
leaderboard a point system
uh
a narrative uh teams etc against walleye
there's really especially in the more
complex and on and i i would venture in
in the future the most successful
applications that alignment process is
there's really a lot of thinking that
goes along i mean i would if i were
making the call center game
i'd have a game designer and three call
center guys
uh uh on that on that team or about that
about that ratio and the same with with
some of these other social metrics i
mean thinking about energy use for
example and reducing energy energy use
it's yeah points kind of work and you
know without much consideration but
it'll work a lot better if you know
a lot about that a lot about that
behavior so that that conversation about
defining the behaviors associated with
the changes that you want finding the
metrics that can be automatically input
into the game finding a way to recognize
those behaviors what do you want people
to do more of less of about the same
is really a tough process still how many
of you have a prius and have played the
leaf game
yes on the first no on the second
yeah so basically you know you get these
little leaves for you know you know
being more eco-friendly as it were and
that's a game but it's like kind of
subtly baked into you know the design of
the car
and um so yes you get you need to get
the business case up and you have a
business model so your business runs but
then you also now well now how do we
make it how do we make it fun and i
argue is that what we're really looking
at is how can we understand and even
change the human architecture that
underlies the stuff that we're doing it
underlies it provides us games are going
to provide us these windows into
changing how
we think feel and behave it'll create
new tools for thought allow us to design
you guys to all design new tools for
thought and if you think about it what
we really need you know to you know cure
aids to end global warming to um you
know bringing on you know conflict
resolution to resolve conflict
resolution is we need to learn how to
chase wonder we need a discovery machine
so you know adding more curiosity when a
surprise to like google google already
does this with the wonder wheel
we need to be able to add more um you
know create a self-motivating task you
know using understanding hard fun like
challenge and obstacles and goals how
that works we also need to create
empathy engines so what we would take
that next step is like yes you've got
the property value argument but then how
do we create empathy and how do we how
do we um how do we what kinds of
mechanics increase empathy or you know
what what would do what would do that
and then um you know finally we've got
you know being able to create eco
simulations because james palges has a
wonderful book on what games can teach
us on video game
about learning literacy and he says if
you master the simulation you master the
content has anybody played um like uh
you know the sim city
simcity yeah yeah all right so after you
played sim city i don't know for me like
it was like you know you know you know i
was up till three in the morning at the
office was the only game that the only
computer would run it then i went home
and i and i drove to work the next day
but it was in this surreal state only a
couple hours asleep but like wow power
lines
sewer oh you know and then the whole
world a whole world that had been
completely and i've been there my entire
life was now suddenly new you know i
come back from a you know playing rock
band with my friends drive across the
san mateo bridge and i'm playing guitar
right for that and you can literally i
can literally see all eight lanes of
traffic every car in both directions
so there's something really interesting
we don't understand what games are doing
for us but i think that that's the next
generation that's what's all up to you
is to take what we're learning in games
take you know take what you enjoy about
games and applying it to these other
contexts well that rolls nicely into i
want to sort of push it out to
get some thoughts and questions but not
just questions i mean some interaction
and are there areas that you all would
like to ask about about the topic but
also some particular areas of
uh greater good that we could talk about
and kind of do gaming at the improv here
and
talk through
how would you do that i've got one
that's a little tangential and that is
that you know machinima took game
engines and made movies using these
games
is there the possibility as opposed to
designing
a game specifically or game dynamics
specifically around
particular goals could we take some
problems we want to solve
and plug them sort of in the back end
into things that happen that in warcraft
i mean if you're trying to solve protein
folding problems or logistical problems
could you in fact sort of program these
in without changing what anybody does in
world of warcraft where
or the topic said three billion hours
a week
in play
is there a way to solve some problems
that happens transparently has anybody
tried to do anything like that
would that be
um the answer is maybe controversial i
suppose yeah the answer is maybe there
was a game called star wars galaxies
when we first started thinking about uh
applications in the enterprise and in
star wars galaxies uh to survive in the
game
you had to make stuff you had to take on
a job and you had to make it
market it sell it
do the whole thing and these were very
sophisticated jobs and there was a job
called
within the doctor category called
pharmaceutical manufacture and we're
playing this game and showing this game
to a bunch of scientists at eli lilly
and in this
who who were interested in gaming
because they had pain points about
collaborative uh science that were very
significant in their development and in
this game you have to
search the galaxy for interesting
catalysts for chemical reactions you had
to actually dock molecules and uh and
think so it wasn't quite the real
science but it was so close uh
and and all the points in the marketing
and and the whole wrapper around the
game could remain the same if you could
actually and they just went to town
thinking about
a very sophisticated collaborative
activity this is not just not something
not a simple behavior this is uh over
over a significant amount of time and
actually spend some time trying to think
about exactly what that would mean and
and
doing a lot of other
uh getting a lot of other advantages in
there as well getting a little bit of
wisdom of crowds involved
uh the leadership issue was very
important if you uh are working at lily
and you invented prozac you're the only
guy that gets to talk in the room uh and
all the young scientists don't get to
talk one of the games that's you know
who cares what you did last week
uh so there were some really interesting
things that came with that and the games
all in all have i mean warcraft has a
thousand apis
in and out so you can
there is there's a a creative there's a
sandbox there for somebody to play uh
and i'm glad you've mentioned that to to
reverse that not to not to spend another
100 million dollars building a warcraft
uh that that'll do scientific
collaboration but actually build that in
so you can go to leadership boot camp in
in uh
in warcraft now working for a company so
instead of you know going to the ropes
course uh and you know getting closer
there why don't uh this this is one
guild this is another another guild and
we're gonna uh uh square off you know
and see so you can get the farthest and
it periodically at the right moments
we'll tell you a little bit about uh
leadership and how group dynamics but uh
it's it's place so i think it's a great
uh thought
are there some so let me push it back
out here um
yes
yeah um
so far everything's been really
fascinating to see these examples where
game dynamics are used in our lives and
we don't even realize
and i wanted to ask
what's been your
experience in differentiating in finding
what it is about certain people that
don't get hooked by games um
you know i'll count myself like in that
you know my younger brother you know
probably spends like 16 hours a day uh
on like three different simultaneous
games online and for the life of me um
you know i've never gotten into
farmville or any of these other things
although i just realized that i
compete with my wife and who can get the
best mileage
just looking at those two examples i
would say uh
you are playing games all the time you
just they're they're more in line with
your social norms and reality and you
don't crave escapism as much it's not
that you don't respond to those game
mechanics or dynamics it's that you're
doing them in your own life and you're
and you're playing in your own life that
example you gave was great i mean people
who really want to do well in school who
want to be recognized who want to speak
on panels i mean there's uh there are a
lot of human
human innate human desires that manifest
themselves all the time so yeah i think
i would add to that uh in the research
we've done uh we've been you know
interviewing players i've been
interviewing players for 20 years so
i and one thing that i that i've learned
is that one the number one reason why
people don't play games and this is
interviewing people in their homes they
have perfect access they got someone to
show them why why why are you not
playing why why
and uh you know usually it's just just
too addictive you know one of my
favorite quotes and this along this line
is uh you know i don't play his kind of
games because somebody has to remember
to take care of the kids
and so it's an interesting point in we
are and i and i've been talking about
this for you know for the past three
years or so four years ago a sense that
you know where if you get you know if
you create a system
that unbalances the human
you know a lot of them are going to
reject
and so actually you know by just trying
to drive your you know your your daus or
you know the week the week the numbers
of hours per week you can actually do in
the long term your business your brand
your game disservice because if they
have to if they have to pull out it's
often like cold turkey no i have to you
know i have to finish my mba i'm not
playing warcraft anymore uh we've had
lots of interviews with that and we've
had people you know people talk about
the people that monetize on facebook you
know those those really you know nine
hundred dollars a month
i mean sorry 900 a year sorry that was
that was insane uh 900 a year uh that's
still insane on virtual goods like what
are you doing
uh and you know i was at their home and
it's like you're you know what are you
doing this is not you know we should not
be spending 900 um but it's you know
it's there's definitely something that
unbalances uh that the health of the
individual um and i really believe that
you know people will you know if you
provide something that's entertaining or
provide some other benefits you know
they're gonna they're gonna come to you
and you really don't need to design
these uh skinner boxes that end in the
end just you know put you on a black
list and too regulated like um you know
like the gambling industry so
i'm just
i'm curious why you asked the question
because
if you're dealing with a game
architecture that you've bolted onto
something and it's not working
which by the way 95 percent of the
people i've talked to about gamification
are dealing with exactly that issue
they're like but we hired programmers
and we you know we put the leaderboard
up and so on it isn't pixie dust you
can't just sprinkle it on something and
expect it to work as gabe zuckerman
wants to say he's right it's a difficult
hard challenge to make this work and
so we do have new tools here and when
they work they're really powerful
but
it's still an art
and they're it's fine it's becoming a
science slowly over time but but um but
it yeah don't underestimate what byron
said it's hard work still to make the
alignment between the behavior you're
trying to get in the real world
and
what the tools are that you're going to
use to incentivize and motivate those
behaviors an example i'd like to share
is um you know back in the day when we
used to remember when we used to milk
cows instead of clicking on them
you know there was inherent engagement
in the task you know you could see if
you were on target the pail would fill
with milk you could talk and help your
co-workers at the end of the day those
pails felt heavy as you carry them back
to the barn all sources of wonderful
natural engagement
but something gets lost in translation
when work went virtual and sort of mouse
driven
and so there's this uh interesting
opportunity to
like really go into like what uh you
know what what can make these uh
mechanics much more uh much more
interesting uh and uh and part of the
part of the real world
what other uh other yes the question
around the measurement is i think that's
a very important part of games i think
it's thinking mostly the professional
space but maybe social as well something
like a sales uh you know sales job is
probably easy to think of a measurement
selling like one pair of jeans is gonna
be the same as another but for something
where there's qualitative difference
between the tasks you know selling
insurance policies or mortgages or doing
um offering legal advice something like
that is there a ceiling to where these
kind of services can be offered such
that you can only really measure
performance on certain kind of tests and
other things have these complex
qualitative measures or is it just that
we're i'm thinking too simplistically
about how you might get a point
now you're talking about measurement of
the effectiveness of the design or of
the behavior of the player uh measuring
sort of the success of the player right
so if you're getting a point for selling
something or finishing a call uh you
know how do you measure the quality of
that call right yeah yeah well it means
a great example like you know hey you
know you can you just put like how many
calls i make a day return a day and then
so you're gonna have people calling and
hanging out calling hanging uphill you
know just to get the number thing or
length of call you know the game is
otherwise so there's a whole menu of
things that that come into play though
when you think about that and and
the games are going to work the best in
cases where there are is quantitative
information that can be uh fed back in
multiple time domains but in a call
center there's a lot of stuff there
there there are moment by moment see
sets uh customer satisfaction surveys
that are being input you could do voice
stress analysis you've got a clock
running on uh call handling duration uh
you've got uh
uh points that maybe a team is
accumulating uh based on uh uh how the
team action is doing and one of the
greatest things that actually happens in
in a place like this whenever you have
a behavior or a piece of work
that is important but is unrecognizably
important because it's so small like
turning the lights out and the glaciers
in antarctica are you know that's a long
causal chain there but you can you can
give recogni
recognition for that if you can find
some metrics so in the call center
example it brings up the the issue of
what is it exactly that that we want
people to be doing what are the
behaviors what could we bring in here
that could be automatically assessed
maybe maybe you could look at
uh and these are all things that are
being done look at facial expressions uh
i mentioned analyzing voice uh looking
at pacing uh there's there's good
research that if if my
the pacing of my cut if i match my
pacing to your pacing in a conversation
you will like me more you know things
like that so you can find ways to bring
these things in just like in the games
put them in a dashboard they're
instantly recognizable it's not that
you're
interfering too much with the task but
they get the games bring up the point of
what is it that we need to be measuring
the most interesting metric i've seen or
that i've been playing with is something
that intuit did which is the i think
it's like the net referral score which
is something about you know how likely
you would be to refer a friend or maybe
actually measure that behavior so after
the call how likely is that customer i
mean how many of those customers
actually bought again or some other
behavior thing might be
because it just does it links it back to
some business goals
yes
sorry mark just to touch a little more
on the level of complexity in a task and
to what degree you can score higher
complexity stuff
there's interesting work out there
being done by colleagues at nasa and
also nikki couture and his team at
carnegie mellon
that shows that yeah if you can
decompose a task well enough and a whole
lot of this comes down to task
decomposition but if you can break down
a high level high skill task well enough
you can get really good traction um
on and really good results on that basis
so i just point you to that work to look
at if you're looking at how to measure
complications and yeah and another thing
too is it's easy to think about
competition but we forget the latin
roots of that word which really means to
come together to better ourselves to and
again you know by pursuing the same goal
and so a lot of mechanics tend to be you
know win lose you know but uh my
favorite restaurant in oakland one of my
favorites is petros and they pool their
tips great service because at the end of
the day you know it's basically
everybody's taking care of everybody
have any questions regarding the
realness of data that is used in a
corporate game uh as context one of my
companies is developing environmental
sustainability solutions and we in turn
are putting more and more gaming
behavior and challenge challenges into
it there's sort of two solutions we
could imagine in one case you're using
the actual latest data from the
company's meters and figuring out what
your footprint is and how things have
changed
or you could switch it so you're dealing
with a hypothetical world to learn from
when you are doing doing the gaming in
which case it's more like some of the
games that i see on facebook in which
you're learning about the impact of
different sustainability initiatives
and so i'm curious in in the corporate
games that each of you are dealing with
and what in what cases is real data
being used and what cases hypothetical
data being used and what kinds of
lessons learned or conclusions are being
drawn by the companies that apply these
jobs i've got a really quick answer to
that because i just talked to
representatives of a foreign government
two days ago who were saying you know we
we've been doing everything metrics
based and and the thing is people just
make up metrics to fill in the forms
because they know that they're being
graded on whether they fill in the forms
that have the metrics or not and so we
know that the metrics are rubbish
um
anytime that people have to actually
write something down or fill out a form
you're on the wrong track you know
they'll be in the system
but
you're also you're now two or three
layers away from reality you need some
way of just
uh
you need a sensor in the environment
that can just track people's behavior to
just see did somebody or did somebody
not do that and if they have to think
about it if they have to fill out a form
if they have to record somewhere that
they did something you're already on the
wrong track
yeah if you if you simplify the world
you you know you clarify your goals you
just you um you amplify the feedback
four things you also want to suspend
consequences
and the more you suspend the
consequences the more playful it is and
then you can pull that in the fantasy
and that's you might want to do for more
dangerous stuff you have stuff that's a
little bit more outside of their box or
you know stuff that's a little bit more
for a field and that might help
you know those kinds of problems make
them more fantasy uh and then take the
stuff that's a little bit more
pedestrian and kind of accomplishable
and put that more in the real world
so what are you doing from the corporate
games is there a
sap system in the back that's doing the
company's accounting and the gaming is
giving you a different different view of
that
yes
yeah no i i think the answer is that
there needs to be there are a lot more
learning and training games than there
are actual work productivity games
because it's just easier data and it's
the only data we can get to right now
but the the real opportunity here is is
to apply this sensibility to the actual
interactions i mean why allow people to
just have fun and have a playful uh
engaging orientation just to learning
and training to go be bored to tears
when when when they leave the training
room why not actually bring that into
the game and say yeah nice to have you
working at our call center
sit down here and start playing when you
get to level seven we'll let you talk to
real customers and uh when you get to
level 14 we'll let you you know you know
run a group or whatever it is so
actually doing it in the work context i
think is where the real advantage is and
that's just a redesign of work it's a
little bit harder with respect to tying
it into the uh
to the actual metrics but you're right
on the right track it's uh you know
salesforce sap oracle they've all got uh
uh calls out now that you could actually
feed uh this information into games and
be incredibly influential what do you
think
uh by bringing that stuff to light
we're playing with that blur and uh with
uh with uh flip you know with tilt flips
adventure uh in 1.5 dimensions where
you've got the cell phones we're working
with the vermont uh energy investment
company and uh we're we're designing
this game it's in prototype stage so
it's real real early but we're doing
this ar which means alternate reality or
augmented reality and uh you basically
can tag uh you know opera you can do an
energy audit we're going to crowdsource
an energy audit
for building so you can like tag those
light bulbs as part of a game it goes
into a database then people can whatever
and then there can be a layer of fantasy
and i when i when i do serious games i
recommend that layer fantasy sort of be
optional because so some people can be
like you know i don't really want to be
in the fantasy park but and then some
people can go well they'll get dressed
up they'll put in the you know they'll
put on the lab coats they'll put on the
hat the funny hats and they'll just go
have fun for the weekend right and other
people will be much more serious about
it but allowing that range because not
everybody really feels comfortable uh
playing one thing i should mention about
platforms we haven't really talked about
but the mobile phone is an amazing it's
going to be an amazing uh very
disruptive force i don't know if it's
clear to you but right now we have over
5.6 billion mobile phones on the planet
cell phones there are more um and that's
3.7 billion cell phone owners there are
more cell phones on this planet today
than there are fm radios
it is the most pervasive technology
communication technology device uh ever
manufactured and it's gotten there to be
that in 10 years
compare that to like a gaming consoles
which is only like 1.1 1.2 billion uh
your gaming consoles handheld consoles
and that's only if you count everything
from 1975 to today
there may be 400 million people playing
on facebook but they're 500 million
smartphones
and that's only in three years
so when we think about gaming and you
think about building your future
businesses be sure to remember that you
know we're really going to ubiquitous
models where these things are
lightweight they got a camera on them
they know where you are there's all
kinds of new things new ways you can
blend real world into that um into
whatever you know kind of game or task
you want
then we have a just real a challenge i
want to test these people with something
you know
what's interesting having 900 bucks on
virtual goods
that's pretty cool does anybody think
they have a really tough challenge for
this crew okay gosh we've got lots of
tough challenges um i mean we haven't
done anything on this side so please
okay uh we talk about social fun and
people yeah it's people from yeah so in
japan yes most successful social game
social mobile yeah largely it shows that
users play with strangers
a lot yes yeah and then my theory is
that in the u.s at least you have to
play with actual friends in order to
increase your user attention
so what do you think is there a cultural
difference or
is my theory wrong
and so before we jump in we've got 10
minutes and we've got at least four
questions and i want to get to everybody
maybe five questions so there we go two
minutes per wow all right yes so um
that's yeah that is a very good question
i need to know a little bit more about
the game in japan compared to here uh
there's but basically uh the research
we've done it has been mostly us we have
done some pilots in korea but we have
not run you know studies in japan i
think that there is an interesting there
is definitely an interesting social
modifier that it does allow you to be
social um in um
it does allow there's some interesting
cultural there are some interesting
cultural differences that i think that i
do think factor into what might make
things
the most the most interesting but i need
to know a little bit more about the game
like what the mechanic is
yeah touch me later that'd be great your
next door neighbor please i have a
challenge for you so you talk about
serious fun yeah
and i figured that so when you're trying
to develop a game
or even an app that has some fun element
to influence behavioral change right now
the trend seems to be like give them the
badge some phone badge right you're very
good the badge mechanic is the most
popular it's not the only one
how do you develop a more personal
mentoring to motivate that person right
so all of you guys have kind of
communication psychology and also
research and industry background here so
how would you do that how would you even
go about thinking right
yeah i haven't i'm an undergraduate from
stanford actually in kagsai and i also
took uh film film production here and
also some programming courses so that's
kind of where i where i come from and
what with serious fun it definitely
badges are definitely a big part of it
but it's collection completion mechanics
it's also repetition and rhythm so
dancing games music games change how i
feel think and behave so those can be
very repetition rhythms so it's setting
up a pattern over time and those can be
very you know that can that can change
your mood that can be very good and then
anything that where you all games teach
and so really giving you something to
think about after the the play is really
important why a badge works is because
it makes you know fiera like yes i just
won that that emotion dies down um goes
away and so it's nice to win a prize
it's a serious fun is all about what
that prize is and it can be a mental
prize it can be all kinds of things it
doesn't have
the economics of rarity doesn't work
exactly exactly i think one of the
things you want to build in there is
just a research layer where you can
actually profile individual players and
run constant av split tests to see who
responds to what
and then you get a much quicker much
better sense of is a bigger badge going
to work for this person is something
more colorful work for that person
something more personal work for this
person and you also get a much better
sense of what's driving individual
people which of the different dimensions
that people play games for is the one is
the reason that that player is playing
the game but you can also get right i
don't want to fail in my task here so
let's make sure i'm just going to sweep
around i see at least these three so
let's start here
let's use games to do do things people
don't want to do
well i think you can't do that i mean
it's taking the portfolio of ingredients
that we've all talked about uh first of
all it's understanding what is the
behavior that you want changed what the
what are the motivations intrinsic and
extrinsic associated with that those
behaviors why is it hard uh you know
what do you want people to do how much
uh how much is it an individual uh
experience versus a social experience i
mean the badge may only work if i can
show it to my friends it's i don't care
about the badge but if i can show it to
my friends and i get so it's it's really
i i think it would work in there in fact
we've got two or three projects within
this large grant game grant project uh
at stanford that it's looking at
transportation and carpooling uh there's
a an engineer on campus uh bellagio
provocar that has uh done uh uh exactly
the gamification uh uh idea that you you
mentioned uh for uh transportation in
india with great success
we had it we ran a pilot for uh
driverless challenge in mountain view
run by adina levin and we just said you
know hey let's let's just take take
photos
take photos of what you're doing you
know put a tag for the game on twitter
we scrape them we put them up on a
website and
you know
it you know it adds some fun to the game
there's also much there's many more
things that they're doing but i'd
recommend looking up her work molly you
had something to have there just i think
also looking at what is the what is the
key reason that they don't want to do it
in the first place and addressing that i
think carpooling is a great example
because there are so many emotional
tie-ins the car is our identity how do
you use identity then you know the
american identity how do you how do you
create the same kind of um i'll use the
word um compulsion that we now have to
recycle if there's not a place to
recycle i i feel like something's wrong
because i've been trained over time and
it's it's cultural it's social it's a
you feel social disgust in the technical
social discussion
throwing something away in the trash
which should be recycled you eventually
eventually tip over and we get trained
to move it
please
a little bit similar but from a
corporate standpoint
i'd love to hear examples or any ideas
you have that incorporation if you're
trying to incentivize employees to
volunteer
to give more of their time so for the
greater good um what would be some
strategies that you can look at
are other companies out there are there
some good examples of companies
yeah but there are here this is the red
team this is the blue team i wonder
who's going to have the most volunteers
that would be yeah then that's that's a
head-to-head competition yeah and and
executing that with
a a lot more style than i just mentioned
but that's that's one way to do it
providing transparency for for that uh
uh providing uh
virtual recognition for that uh creating
uh ways in which you can instantiate the
success uh not the failure uh that
doesn't work as well but the success of
the of the two teams uh i mean it's just
all the all these different ingredients
there are specific examples there's a
health uh care large healthcare plan
that's uh using game mechanics to uh uh
look do uh uh
employ volunteer uh right now with with
success i would i would just take up a
big white board draw a line down the
center and on one hand put um social
emotions involved with volunteering so
generosity gratitude you know the
feeling of elevation you see some human
act of human kindness and on the other
half of the board put mechanics these
are things that you can do uh in a you
know game like world of warcraft you
know you get you get a health health
pack and if i give it to you i feel
generous you feel gratitude you might
feel elevation seeing human kindness and
then later in the game you know you can
give it back to me or you know something
like that and then that those emotions
kind of roll you know roll through the
game so you want to think on that other
side like what what kinds of actions
would then get us to that um those
different emotional states
i'm reading a book right now called
zilch by nancy lublin that is lessons
from the non-profit world for for-profit
for the for-profit world
and
how do you motivate people in context
where you don't have effectively money
in power they're volunteers and you need
to motivate them and they talk about how
do you bring
um
nonprofit activities into for-profit and
how do you get people to do that it's
it's an interesting i'm enjoying it it's
an interesting book and it's not exactly
your point but it's a lot of the same
how do you
how do you motivate people to do things
where it's not about tying their pay to
it
yes sir
how could it help
how could it happen you should you
should uh come visit our lab we've got
three whole projects going on
for uh for games uh
one of the has anyone played brain aged
on the nintendo ds what was really
interesting about that particular game
is you play it basically it's almost
it's almost math flashcards but a little
more sophisticated you write down um the
multiplication they've got little number
games and stuff like that what's
fascinating about that design and i
think it's the two things one is that
there's a social ui there's a little
character that says hey good job or
whatever but then the other thing is
that you can only do you if you do three
of the challenges uh you'll actually get
a little stamps you can put on that
calendar like yes i got a stamp today
and you get to design the stamp you can
you get to place the stamp but if you
play that that challenge a second time
in that day you don't you get score but
you don't get credit
and so to level up in that game you have
to come back it rewards you for coming
back every day
and so just by designing that that kind
of design over time then that's what
builds a habit so it's not like i played
brain age for five hours and i leveled
up because you actually won't that won't
do as much as doing 15 minutes every day
there's a there's a customer of ours uh
hope lab who is oh yeah they're amazing
they're doing some great stuff health
hero they've got great stuff yeah zamzi
is a product for for kids who are having
weight problems and it actually tracks
their activity level during the day at
night they plug their pedometer in and
they get to use the
credits they've earned during the day
for all of their activities to interact
socially so really tying in what kids
want to do with what they might not be
inclined to do to create this feedback
loop and then train them uh over time
they've seen i think 30 increase uh in
activities for kids involved in this
program yeah if you haven't won them one
area that i think is going to be really
ripe for a lot of
commercial activity and startup activity
and that is the general area of
compliance you know 25 to 40 percent of
prescriptions that are written
are not filled or our medicines not
taken properly on time uh this is a huge
issue perhaps you know
even one of the most important issues a
lot of game mechanics can be applied uh
to that if executed well
and if you apply to that you want to
look at that that core word compliance
what
i mean it's like you know i'm telling
you what to do you want you need to
comply to my rules that's not very
that's not game thinking right that's
not very that's not very playful so
think about you know start there and
then you know design your game your game
from that it's not comply we want to you
know you're not someone saying you must
do this but do something that makes it
uh because people are saying no don't
want to like don't want to fit in that
box but if you're starting a company say
the word compliance yes yeah actually
funding yeah it's very good
yeah yeah yeah yeah actually when
everything coming out of my mouth from
the designer perspective that's that's
me
um i think we're we're out of time i'm
going to ask one i have the the luxury i
guess asking one last question and that
is
look 20 years down the road will we be
sitting here talking about a set of
tools called game dynamics or will this
be all so integrated into the fabric of
everything we do
that it'll just be
part of it it won't be a separate
toolbox it'll just be part of the
fundamental place we start the latter
yeah
there's no question in my mind like i
said earlier is that games uh well games
are the medium for the 21st century
and games are really taking interface
design to that next interaction design
to that next level
uh the stuff that we think and learn
about as you know hci human interaction
you know ui design all of that's going
to be taken to that next level just like
you know film introduced two
technologies you know the frame for
attention and the cut
to compress time to increase emotional
engagement well games added choice
and we've had 35 years of inventing this
language of games just like there's a
language of cinema we're not done yet
with the language of games but it's
going to go right into interaction
design and you're not going to see it as
a separate discipline
well i'd like to thank all of you for
your attention and your questions and
molly nicole mark byron thanks
for your time and thoughts is
fascinating and i hope you all do good
work in this area
great